[Music]
christian and i have a little nephew two
of them actually um and the older one
who's about was now three just had a
birthday
um
he is obsessed with the cartoon
character nature cat it's a show on pbs
i think right where um
the lead character nature cat uh the
titular kitcheller role um he uh
explains nature to kids it's a really
great idea and really wonderfully
executed
we recently got nature cat to record a
little message for our nephew and it's
truly i think my favorite thing i've
ever seen the video of our nephew
hearing this message and hearing
his favorite character animated
character say his name and seeing his
mind blown i mean you can see the moment
his mind is it's easily in the top five
funniest things i've ever seen and the
top five
most heartwarming yeah i've ever seen
those two things together
oh man i wish we could show you but we
can only talk about it because we don't
have our own kids
maybe one day uh anyway for now we do
have a podcast and here it
life is be a dream
you're listening to life for short i'm
your host justin long life could be a
dream
[Music]
and with me as always is that one of the
worst introductions no i think that was
pretty oh yeah wow okay um my brother
who's judgement i trust very much which
is i'm very supportive you are
supportive
uh
excuse me
sorry um
then you feel really self-conscious now
when you cough
you know i know i meant to ask you this
last night you've been coughing a lot in
the last 24 hours i have yeah and i
figured it was just the weather changing
yeah i think it is i'm prone to
allergies
and um see
seasonal change really affects me i was
just thinking i i knew i was going to
say that sentence and i um i started
laughing because i realized how like
nerdy i sound it's the new channel
everyone's officially i know it'll
change there are very few people who are
above that
i bet um uber benches like dave bautista
yeah he never he's not i feel like he's
never been allergic to anything yeah are
you proud of me for not saying future
guest
were you i mean were you
i was for like three and a half seconds
um but yeah our our nephew when he heard
that right
god i
i just we take so many videos and photos
of our nephews like they're just the
best i mean everyone does this is
nothing new but um
this is one that i know i will cherish
for the rest of my life but this kid is
also
i know everyone says this but he's super
special he's like he's already reading
he's very bright adorable adorable yeah
he's so to see his
mind his already very sharp mind
register that his favorite animated
character saying is knew his name knows
him was
it was just beautiful it was like the
the best thing i've ever seen the
reaction because also as an actor i like
to take notice of
extreme reactions you know when somebody
is uh
surprised or or was taken aback by
something um it's it's such i mean you
see it on instagram all the time all
those great they got a lot of great
videos and stuff but um with kids
especially my agent logan who i hope is
listening posted a video of his son
who's a little bit older than our nephew
um but it was really cute he was in the
car
going through the car wash and
he was amazed by it just like
you know he was pointing things out and
and i was
started texting with my agent about like
you know how great it is to when a kid
is so
uh entertained by such things things we
take for granted and i kind of it
brought me back to when i was in the do
you remember going through the car wash
as a kid and like how cool it was it was
like kind of scary and
it was a really it was a wild ride it
was a wild ride yeah well the reason
we're talking about our nephew
and nature cat
is because
our guest today on life is short is
nature cat himself yeah yeah i hope
you're sitting down
uh all you nature cat enthusiasts our
guest today is taryn killum who
in addition to being nature cat is so
many more things i in fact only recently
discovered he he was the voice of this
uh and for the record this interview
during this interview taryn
is taryn he's not he's not doing the
interview as nature cats oh yeah so
don't rush
yeah because and according to him it's a
very difficult voice to do because it
requires a lot of energy uh it
he has to kind of strain to do it
because it's if you know the voice it's
a bit like roger rabbit that's what he
says right yeah and now that's what i
hear but um i hadn't heard that in in
the character before it's tally ho it's
it's up
i can't really do that but it's pretty
close yeah it's up like it tapped like
this um but it's he's so gifted when it
comes to uh he's just a really very
gifted performer and it was extremely
generous of him to blow her nephew's
mind he he didn't have to do that but he
left this really sweet message yeah a
really kind person he really is um and
his equally kind wife uh is a former
guest of the show friend of the show
yeah kobe smalders um they actually just
sent us because i did a taran organized
in another very kind gesture organized a
fundraiser fundraising event for when we
all vote uh we did it the other day with
some some very funny people on zoom
and uh he i thought it was such a nice
gesture that he even organized it he and
kobe just sent us a bunch of delicious
looking cookies
they're just like a couple i know i know
you'll hear me gush about them and
uh go on about them um but i just really
really admire uh taryn as a performer
too and um he is such a kind person but
uh
i've always right away liked him i
remember meeting him in
new york we were i was with some cast
members of snl and it was the first
season he was on i think yes definitely
he had just joined the cast and i was
meeting up with um
some other cast members to go sing
karaoke and uh
right away i was like who is this guy
because he was he was so funny obviously
singing here he's also such a good
singer uh we all know he's he's nuts
in the hit show hamilton hamilton on
broadway yes he's uh he's a showman the
great white way
yeah he's he's also on the show the
board just once or twice you also might
know him you might know him from single
parents uh
you guys know him from snl mostly he was
like i thought he was
the he was my favorite snl cast member
of that era i thought he was the most
really
diverse and consistent committed he was
always committed he was incredible on
that show yeah um and god i miss
watching him on that uh his enjoyment of
performing is so palpable you know
palpable and how you know him through uh
so then i met him with kobe uh at my
friend nick panesa's
wedding i sat across from that oh really
yeah right away just uh fell in love
with those two and then started going to
i would see taran perform at the
groundlings because my friend nick was
in that sunday cast and
right away he recognized what a what a
great performer he was so funny so funny
and a few weeks ago we did we can't
really talk about it because it hasn't
aired yet but justin and i did a game
show
over zoom
i it's very called a game show right
yeah yeah uh and i think what else you'd
say and taryn and his friend were um
our competitors right in the game show
so we talk about that a little bit yeah
that's good context yes in the beginning
you yeah uh-huh um hey let's get to it
okay wow stop beating around the bush
you're killing killing this
intro
okay uh you know i like to lower the bar
the comedy bar it's i think it's a nice
thing for the guests because then they
um it's so much so easy for them to
surpass it well mission accomplished
okay here he is
uh my catch up with my my friend taryn
killen life could be a dream sweetheart
hello hello
[Music]
i know you wanted christian on the show
which he was very flattered by
but he didn't want it he didn't he
wasn't going to do it well i'm sorry
he's not here i'll tune in i'll tune in
for the for the post sesh therapy
breakdown you know you know what's
really interesting is he mentioned his
wife a lot but that you can clearly you
can tell there's a ton of affection in
the relationship
and i i i really smoked i really like
that
also he's still very bitter about the
celebrity game face you can hear it in
his voice it's the first thing he
brought up
christian has like h john benjamin sound
voice to me has he gotten that before i
don't know is he is h john oh is he the
bob's burger yes guy yes yes then yes
but i love i love this podcast thank you
for having uh
we love you you know i
we were joking the other day because you
joked on the show the kevin hart show
that uh i hadn't
asked you to do this yet and i swear i
swear to god i swear to god we've wanted
you on for so long but i think because
we're we're friends
i always just assumed we'd do it
when we saw each other you know i get
that um but who knows when that now is
going to be so yeah we uh truly how are
you guys doing i mean without getting
too personal let's get heavy we're in
trouble justin
give christian some good fodder i don't
trust my wife i don't trust her um
we're good we're as we're as good as
anybody can be in this time uh we have
two daughters they're back at virtual
school now
um
which is less than ideal but but all of
our all the teachers and school
administration are working so hard to
make it as
pleasant and painless as possible
everybody's trying to rally for someone
who doesn't have kids like what does
that mean when they're in virtual school
they're in their rooms now you have to
be nearby we have an eleven-year-old
who's in sixth grade so she is yeah
she's
self-managing but even then you wanna
check in and make sure that she's on top
of it because you know right kids are
small people and people are smart and
people are lazy
and so you know she you know she's
quickly finding the loopholes of like
well they said just finish the worksheet
and i did it really fast so i don't have
to be there anymore and
now i'm oh god i'd be the worst
i'm thinking about myself yeah in sixth
grade um but she's but she's also like
she's a very uh uh honest person so
the second we open the door if she's not
fully engaged on the laptop she's like i
just felt i needed to clean my book
drawer
yeah yeah you listen to the show you've
heard me talk about how impressive i
think you and kobe are and
as a as a couple as people
what do they think of you what do your
kids think of you i i feel like they're
so lucky to have you as parents but i
wonder what their perspective is that's
very nice of you and thank you for every
nice thing you've ever said about me and
kobe um
so in terms of what they think if you're
asking what they think of us and what we
do in our careers we're just always very
open and and transparent about why we do
it which is we love performing we love
telling stories we love the craft and
the technique of acting of television of
film
our eldest in particular expresses
interest in following
uh down that path and so
we kobe and i were very quickly on the
same page of
we support you and whatever your passion
is whatever you want to endeavor and we
will support you and and except for
acting except for acting so
here's your here's your chemistry set
let's do it
um
it's about it's about studying it that
it isn't a skill you can build even
though it's not right it's not as easy
to define as being an engineer or a
mathematician
there is technique to it and there is
study and there is history and if and if
you want to participate great you're
going to do it with your friends you're
going to do it in a safe environment and
then encourage you
to educate yourself to develop an actual
craft
that must be harder taryn to impress
upon a kid now than when we were kids
because of all the
avenues open to them in terms of being
performers or
just doing it for the wrong reasons as
they say on the bachelor you know
doing it to be famous or to be popular
um
it must be more confusing now to kind of
guide a kid through that i think
definitely with youtube stars and social
media and the immediate access that
everybody grants
it is seemingly almost entirely
motivated by self-promotion and just
attention-seeking i think both kobe and
i struggle with but are also very aware
that you don't get into this industry
because you don't want anybody to pay
attention to
having to define your boundaries and
your parameters of what you're
comfortable with sharing being in the
public eye versus what you want to
preserve for yourself for your own
personal life
takes time i think it takes time i think
it takes trial and error what's an
example of an error that that you may
have
in terms of that that you may have
committed like just getting a little too
revealing too much or being
when you're finding your foothold of how
to balance those two there's a couple
there's a couple i think i think our our
strongest limits are with our children
and i think kobe and i
we were young parents we were 27 when we
had our first kid and we were we drew a
very hard line of like we'll never talk
about them we'll never see their name
when that you know
yeah
and
and i think i think in making it a
bigger deal like that i think if you're
in an interview scenario and we've
learned this over time that if you're
like i'd prefer not to talk about that
that just that just that creates a kind
of negative energy and also
shines more of a light onto it than if
you totally
oh it's great we love it it's the best
thing we've ever done and then it's a
boring answer and then people move the
friends
right and you demystify it yeah well why
aren't they yeah yes
um yeah but then but then like uh you
know
then outside of children there's just
being in a relationship where you're
both performers when you're both actors
um
and like i remember early in in the
twitter
my twitter career
um i was watching the americans and i
just tweeted out carrie russell you're
the other one for me
and that was literally the only time
like truly like in in a very strong way
that kobe expressed like that hurt my
feelings that that didn't feel good
because
you're putting that out so publicly and
and i had to sort of define
i don't actually
think that i'm going to meet carrie
russell and then be able to negotiate
some sort of polygamous
situation
dot dot dot i also don't want to rule it
out because i'm open to all things and
i'm i'm progressive as hell
right but having to
um then set
uh a boundary for oh yeah oh yes there
are people who
invest in a public way in our private
relationship and i need to be conscious
of that of of kobe's feelings and of my
own feelings and that
being flippant or being jokey
about what is private
is maybe irresponsible you know at times
the strange thing is that we are like
you said in this business where
the truth is you could very easily work
with carrie russell you get a call next
week where like you know
you're in a thing with her now and then
it becomes like
if if in fact you were you were joking
but it now becomes like something that
she might have to yeah i think i'm too
aware of sort of the uh the greater than
less than
i have been a fan of carrie wrestle
since the mmc mickey mouse club reboot
but i am only making that joke publicly
because i know
there is no scenario where yeah i would
ever leave kobe i am too happy in my
relationship with her and i respect her
too much as a person so i make the joke
because it's so ludicrous right right
even even in
carrie russell and i work together you
know and like oh we really get along i'm
i'm i'm
so in love with kobe and i'm so
dedicated to her and and that's been
part of our relationship journey is sort
of defining
you know
making her a priority and and and making
my commitment to her
um something that i'm i'm constantly
working on but that i constantly
appreciate too that i'm able to build
this this life this
um partnership you alluded to this
earlier you're talking about your kids
that that you know that what you do in
the life that you guys have as actors
performers pales in comparison to
when you have kid you know that life and
at what point did that
was that a thing that just becomes
apparent as soon as they're born i mean
walk me through that because i i would
love to know what that one day would
love to know what that feels like but
uh
yeah it's an interesting question
um because i would say like my
priorities
personal and career have evolved
constantly um again no one gets into
this business to be like i'm gonna be a
very private person
um a friend of mine once said like we're
all a little insane because you only
start
doing this you only start acting you
only become a performer because you're
like hey look at me i deserve to be
looked at
right i have something more than
your anybody else kind of thing
right well taran sorry i know we're
jumping around but when did that when
when was that apparent to you to your
family when did that start defining you
in your relationship to your family
let's say pretty early on pretty early
on i like i'm a
come from sort of a show busy family or
showbiz of jason at least like my dad
was a struggling actor when he was a
young man my mom a struggling musician
oh i didn't know my mother's
uncle by marriage is robert stack
oh wow um so there's you know
there was the biz was in our blood
already and and when i was very young
like uh five five and a half my mom
uh
like took me and my two younger siblings
to a commercial agent like had the
wherewithal to know like yeah this could
be a thing you kids are cute and
precocious and i've seen i've seen the
head shots yeah yeah so i was the only
one who could hang with it i was the
only one that could walk into a room and
be like yeah i love milkshakes you know
[Music]
but my parents were a good balance of
like we think this is something you
could excel at but
if you say no no pressure like it was a
good balance so there'd be bursts
there'd be like you know anywhere from
like like
three to six months where i'd be
auditioning and then the second i was
like i don't want to do this as boring
where it's like we're done great oh and
then like school plays came into it and
then i was like oh i could do that like
we moved to big bear when i was um seven
and they shot a movie up there and they
needed local extras
so i like that was an event that kind of
wait what was the movie it's called i'm
sure you know
um
i'm sure you know some people in it uh
it was called a pig's tail there's a
camp movie called a pig's tale
and
andrew keegan
uh-huh right sure yes yeah okay so he
was in he was a um lisa the oldest
daughter from
uh mrs doubtfire
oh
k is it yes not least at all not um
christian can't stand i mean this is we
have to cut this out because it's really
sensitive but he hates the the
performance of the young mauro wilson in
mrs doubtfire he finds
really great mrs doubtfire what about us
not a matilda fan then either probably
great
what do your impression of christian not
liking mera wilson uh you you know i i
understand she's a child i understand
she's a little girl that's a kid but
there's something
it's so visceral it's almost you know
what it is i think it's almost
i think it's like an audible thing i
think in the same way that dogs react to
whistles there is some pitch some
vibration some sound of her voice that
literally
just like digs under my skin and wants
me to pull out my skeletal structure no
offense to her it's not a personal thing
i think it's honestly i think it's
science
that's good that's pretty good
so
so what when you so when you're up at
i'm also fascinated by the fact that i
don't talk to you about this uh your
childhood at in big bear because if for
people who haven't been there it's very
uh it's quite rural and woodsy and it's
very remote um
people vacation there but but for the
most part i i've never met anyone who
grew up there it's a resort town it's
very close to la though like no traffic
you're there in two hours but it is a
resort town
um the reason we moved there is that my
parents could afford to own land there
could own a house so as a financial
reason they all there's a decent school
system
but for me
and and my two younger siblings i have
two older sister sisters who are pulled
out of high school to move there and so
like they have a very different
relationship to be not bad
but might be it was very idyllic for us
in that it was seasonal and it was
outdoorsy and it was small town and
everybody knew everybody else and
we really loved our time there and i
think are quite nostalgic for it and try
to go back at least once once or twice a
year do you still have do they still
have the house there or no no when i was
16 we moved back down to the south bay
to manhattan beach um because i was
going to laksa which is oh that's right
with ronnie with ronnie with josh groban
oh really previous uh life is short
podcast
guess who you've known not as long as me
that
[Laughter]
right
again we're not as close so i figured
well we should do the zoom thing and
then since we're closer meet up in
prison
it was a great interview it's a great
interview josh is a great guy
but he didn't mention you but uh yeah i
noticed that
yeah
did um do you still know him do you
still know people from i mean you know
ronnie he and i will keep in touch you
know it's like maybe maybe a text every
two to three months something like that
when we were in new york both doing
shows he was doing
um
uh
the the comet show um oh yeah
i should know this he talked all about
it on the podcast yeah yeah the name of
which escapes me the uh
i want to say harold in the purple comet
that's what it was
yeah
that's definitely what it will always be
now uh
but he was that was literally right next
door to hamilton when i was doing oh
there so that was fun we got to go out
to lunch a couple of times and reconnect
and uh because we were pretty close in
high school actually we were we were
buds in high school
and you were on that kind of musical
theater because he had talked about that
a musical theater track that you were on
what
what was it why did you and i didn't
know that you did mad tv at such an
early age i know you were 19. i'm all on
tv
how did you really are because it's like
josh said something similar is that
people were surprised once he started
acting but once you started doing
musical theater um
that that's something that you had kind
of been on the path toward doing what
derailed you into sketch um
the the fluke of of of mad tv so you
know i i got infrequent jobs through
childhood like like in big bear i became
sag because i did like a reenactment for
unsolved mysteries and i did a small
part in naked gun 33 and a third [ __ ]
gunther that was it that's what i read i
was like what yeah wow yeah all over the
map and then and then went to this arts
high school and started
uh you know i was there as a theater
major as was josh and then there was
like a friday elective you could do in
the second half of the year where you
put on a big musical production and i
didn't do that until my last
year my senior year we did a vida but
i'd always done musical theater in you
know at the school place and big bear
and stuff that was always a
passion and love of mine
and graduating from laksa i went to ucla
as a musical theater major
i was doing a year at college studying
for musical theater oh my god while also
auditioning for guest stars and pilots
and stuff and like oh wow i got real
close on smallville
to be like superman's best friend
oh wow
and like and i almost got that and then
like felt that that was my oh that was
my shot and i blew it and i didn't get
it and then
almost a month like it had to have been
within the same month just because i
remember like being so down about that
and then getting the call from my
management going hey they're looking for
for mad tv cast members and we know
you've never done sketch you've never
really done improv but you're always so
funny when you come in the office that's
literally what they said
you're always you always hang out in
this office doing bits and in doing
impressions of everybody
is that something you'd you wanted try
and i was like yeah
cool what a weird what a chat like yeah
i'd only ever done network pilot movie
audition roles uh-huh and let me just
wait taryn did you so you would do as
you did with christian you do
impressions of people that you were just
in your life that you knew but did you
have like a stable as you do now of like
known people that you did um yeah you
know what i would do is i would do like
at that time the wb was huge and
dawson's and like american pie and cruel
do you do a pc
um
yes
yeah
um
christian i love doing there's a there's
a scene where he says goodbye to an
older lover of his and yeah the teacher
yeah but i think her name's
tamara tamara and he goes by tammy
mine was mine was like more
it's always like a gimmick there's
always like some kind of game or some
sort of rhythm but oh yeah his was that
he would if he'd have to do long
monologues josh would like become a
little bit lazier with his jaw he had a
pretty lazy jaw so
yeah doesn't so let me get this straight
you enjoyed this
[Music]
you're not listening to me yeah yeah if
stephen
was i i remember james bender was always
forcing it up oh funny
yeah i think i i think the van der beek
i did was a varsity blues you know
oh let's see oh yeah like i don't want
your life and it was just like i don't
want your wife and i don't want like i
just found a lot of words that rhymed
with life and it was just him walking
around i don't need a knife exactly i
don't want you're not exactly like it
was just that and him going into drawers
and stuff it was i mean i was 19. i had
no idea what i was doing but i just did
so
i did so many and like
it kept spiral they just kept calling me
back they're like yeah you are
fun and they just and like after seven
or eight auditions they're like we want
to hire you as a featured player and i
was yeah that was 19 and you
to me impressions are uh it's like an
art form it's a type of acting that i
don't think ever gets to do credit as an
acting piece so like
the fact that you can do brad pitt and
michael cera equally convincingly
they're such different people
that shows such range and and level of
commitment that i've always admired so
you are so wonderful at impressions that
i know you love them i
struggle with
have always struggled with impressions
and and really
and still do if i'm being honest like in
taking pride of them because
to me it's like a it's a musical mimicry
and where i've been able to kind of give
myself more credit
is is the observational
element to it of of noticing ticks and
mannerisms and points of view
um that is the role of an actor like
that is what an actor actually yeah for
sure
doing like hey do do that impression of
that thing
like one that that version of it is is a
party trick thing that i think like like
what i just wanted to do
i've gotten better with it but there's
definitely a time where i was trying
real hard
to
break out of that like i left matt and
was that snl did snl force you to kind
of figure out how to get better at that
or come to terms with your skills yeah
it was it was sort of the build up to it
because
like jim carrey has always been kind of
my comedy hero like he's always i've had
many but he's always been number one
just like where he came on the scene and
where i was in my life at that time just
every halloween was dressing up as
whatever character he'd played recently
on the school ground like just you know
reenacting his ventura the mask dumb and
dumber
cable guy oh my god yeah yes it is yes
it is
yes
it is
to me
freaking that kills me talk about
commitment
i know i know oh that scene i mean i
there are scenes in that movie that i
like we talked to chad apatow about it
but that i marvel at um and the one with
the eggs the screen don't let your eyes
get cold scrambie eggs
screaming
it was coming
by this time you
um by what i mean just that the timing
that those two had so good
you know the girl but a big part of him
is that he started out as an
impressionist and a mimic and then
trashed his act like he literally could
have been danny gans or whatever and
gone to vegas and been making millions
of dollars a year with this house act
doing impression like that was easy that
was easy yeah and he threw him away for
all original stuff and that's what
brought him to living color and like my
struggle with like
i'm just copying somebody else i really
would love to find those original
characters
um when i left mad tv so many of the
people i worked with there that i
respected had come from the groundlings
so i went back and i started taking
classes there i didn't know you had gone
back to groundlings yeah yeah because
like
like michael hitchcock who is the writer
at matthew knows there jennifer joyce
and and michael mcdonald like so many of
the people that i really respected had
trained there and like being cast on mad
tv they're like if you ever want to come
by and do a show and i went and watched
my first gas show and i was like i could
never do this no way i was terrified
wow and then when i left i was like you
know mad tv
was exhilarating because it was like it
was i'm on a sketch i've always loved
comedy i've always been a fan of this
and they asked me to do it but i just
didn't know what i was doing and i knew
and by the end of it i was doing better
and they actually like asked me to come
back but like at a reduced like episodic
number you know they're like we like you
i'm not sure and i was like
i you know my reps at the time were like
forget them move on no
we like you we don't like yeah yeah and
i was like but uh good job um so i just
knew like okay i do love this art form i
do love this this um
this genre i need to kind of train and
so that was going back to groundlings
and and i also knew like if i leave mad
now and if i work really hard and i
really set my sights on snl i do think
it's a possibility life could be a dream
sweetheart
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and would
shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondery plus in
apple podcasts or the wandery app
[Music]
hello hello again
[Music]
looking back what do you think it was
that the mad tv people
felt needed
work or wasn't right for the show or or
that you needed to hone i just think
that i i just think that i was
minimum
minimum eight or nine years younger than
every other employee there like it was
it was you know mad tv was a more
seasoned cast in terms of structuring a
sketch like the structure of a sketch i
had no clue about that i knew here's the
voice i do here's what a high school
teacher of mine was like and it was like
raw and just energy and just like paper
but but no focus no no shape
going to groundlings like put a big
emphasis on
on trying to develop original stuff and
trying to develop characters
but when you have this asset of mimicry
and impressions and stuff like that
people do love it people do love i know
who that is and that they do do that
they do sound like that and it is such
an asset that even getting to snl
the stuff i got on much more was was
going to be impression stuff or the
stuff that i would be assigned would be
impression stuff because i just had
access to that how does that work on snl
on monday when do you just pitch certain
people you've been working on um
do you just say hey i've been doing a
michael stare impression i just want to
throw it out there yeah it's different
it's i think michael cera's part of one
of my three auditions i auditioned three
times like on stage for the show twice
one year and then the third time the
following season
no kidding
now how does that work taren like if you
i would think just my own insecure actor
brain i would think well i didn't get it
i didn't get it once then i eat it twice
what motivates you to go back a third
time the first time because that sort of
confident voice that that said like if i
ever get a chance to audition i think
i've got a shot but i know that i may
never get a chance to audition i knew
that um
so when lauren came to the sunday
company and they were seeing people
i could kind of feel the energy and then
just go he was in the audience in l.a at
the time
he was actually he'd actually come to
see naseem i think i think naseem had
been recommended by tina because they
had a connection
um but then he flew me and jillian bell
um and naseem and then uh greg roman
another performer that was in sunday
with us
all four of us went out and i just
treated that like graduation i was just
like no matter what happens
we got we got seen we got picked and so
the first time was just like
joy joy joy sell it like i can't believe
we're here like i rented a limo for all
of us to pick us up at the airport and i
made a mix cd of like all new york songs
so frank sinatra's new york new york's
playing as we're coming through the
lincoln tunnel
oh man
we're like i'm just all about it and i
was like let's go to a fancy restaurant
to celebrate after you know yeah and
then getting called for the second time
then it got called then it was real then
it was like they're really paying
attention to you they're really
considering you
and i did psych myself out a little bit
now it's mine to lose it feels more like
it's trying to lose as opposed to it's
mine to possibly win like i'm oh yeah in
the competition i could be a winner and
now it's like i have been selected and
now if i don't live up to the
expectation it's my fault right
also by the time you're auditioning your
first audition you're like i'm going to
give them my a material i'm going to
show them everything i got i'm going to
cut all the fat and then they go later
we want 10 new minutes five new minutes
whatever and you're like i have to use
all the fat
and then after that naseem got called in
for a meeting because that's a thing
like when you go in with a group you're
all comparing notes like did you hear
anything did you hear
this team got flown out to meet with
lore
so like i knew that at that moment it
wasn't for me but we were told by the
talent department
he's on our radar he's still in the mix
like it's not now but it's not never
there was definitely a portion of my
brain that dedicated
my the next year performing at the
groundlings to
developing more material
with a specific purpose of something
that could possibly be used on snl what
did you do in that third audition oh man
um so when lorne came to see the sunday
show
i was performing a sketch that sarah
baker and i wrote that we just called
french dance which was a sketch that i
we ended up doing multiple times on snl
which is just like teen hipsters in a
cafe
and then whatever
my american mind thinks isn't a popular
song from there comes on the jukebox and
what that dance party looks like
oh that's fine it's like kind of
combining like
the cliches and stereotypes that i feel
americans have about french people like
jerry lewis absurdism
like 1960s beatnik hipster that you know
so he that's what he came in and saw so
i hadn't done that in any of my
auditions so i brought it back because i
knew that that was the thing that lauren
had seen that made him go yeah fly him
out
um
it's just trying to think it must be so
strange trying to get into his head
based on certain clues that you have
from what he saw
but i but i do i think i knew and and
this has been since reinforced having
watched you know years year after year
of people auditioning like you got to do
what makes you laugh like that is that
like like the the rest of the strategy
like maybe but you could just as easily
strategize thinking that they'll they'll
feel this way that makes them feel the
exact opposite
um and it's just like what makes you
what is this is what's funny to me
and and then also cut the fat like cut
the air out get to the jokes
um
and that's that's what matters
well i'm sure a lot of what you respond
to and correct me if i'm wrong having
seen a lot of these auditions is just
the it's not necessarily i've thought
this about like will ferrell certain
people that i've seen the auditions on
the dvds but there's a sense of um of
joy and play
that is so palpable it's it's it's not
so much that it's like the funniest
material or it's just how loose and fun
are they yeah yeah if you can get if you
can let some personality shine through i
think that that is a huge part of it too
yeah but who knows who knows too
and and then when you're on when i mean
you get that call and you've got a
family then in l.a
i mean just logistically
what what what goes through your mind
you must be excited but then is it like
oh boy now what does this mean yeah it's
it was
certainly not a breeze um it was not a
breeze and
like
i was flying back and forth kobe was on
how i met your mother our daughter was a
year old i'd also like i'd been the
primary caretaker that whole first year
right because kobe's working full-time
i'm just doing groundlings you know
sunday nights and wednesday nights
pretty much so like she's mine she's my
and now and that's like
certainly the most heartbreaking and
still have regrets about the time away
time spent
um
there's there's excitement you know it's
your first year and it's your dream job
so there's excitement that helps
motivate that and and and if i'm being
completely honest like getting on a
plane after taking care of a child for a
year straight feels kind of nice
yeah
yeah
but every i couldn't believe that i mean
you're saying like you made a commitment
to kobe and earlier in the show and
that's the first thing that came to my
mind was the years that you because i
remember seeing you out there and
i know how grueling that schedule is i
don't know firsthand but i've seen
friends go through it and
to go back and forth
every week you were doing that
every every second or third week pretty
much like i'd stay for the run of shows
and then
going into and hiatus week i would like
stay up at the after party book the
first flight out of jfk or newark like
you know it's a 5 6 7 am flight stay up
all night go to the after after hop in a
cab and just and get home and i'd be
home by like 10 in the morning because
you're flying west
um
but and right away you take care of you
you don't have time to even take care
just like yeah get back get me back to
my kid give me back yeah you know and
i'm sure like i'm sure there are aspects
of that energy that's not healthy of
like i'm here now and what you know what
i mean it's like whoa calm down bro you
have not been here for two three
at the beginning of the season possibly
even four weeks like you need to
freaking cool your jets you still have
like performance energy yeah exactly
like hey
is this a sketch
i'm just learning words dude i'm just
learning words
um
no it was not great it was not great it
was also complicated because there were
things that were great like both kobe
and i were working that alone is great
but then at the same time you're
sacrificing the social a little bit
right where
a lot of the other cast and writers on
their weeks off are like hey want to
hang i want to see a movie want to
create shared experiences want to go to
on vacation together
um
and so i you know i have to exclude
myself from that you know it's all
trade-off but yeah also
doing the work with my family there when
they moved out in my in my fifth season
it got harder with them there because if
they're not in town
i'm all right what else am i gonna do i
gotta give my all to the show and now
with them there it's like hey you know
there's a winter concert i want to get
to let's let's write this werewolf
sketch and get out of here you know
oh that's interesting yeah yeah so there
was trade-off it's but that's life man
what did you think of as your function
on the show were you the guy who do you
ever see yourself that way like i'm what
phil hartman was doing i'm it was it was
like a big struggle of mine on that show
for sure in terms of
what i
wanted to be versus what i was being
used as
what you know my ego is like i'm not
anybody i'm tearing you know like that
sort of thing yeah not being so
unrealistic to know that there are roles
in their services and there's a
familiarity to the rhythm that people
watching at home and in the studio are
expecting but coming in what i wanted
forte is is still like like all-time
favorite to me forte and fred and and
the absurdity of what they would do and
the craziness and like the
you know a sketch called the falconer
and just like
base
the base and non-sequitur and gross
insecurity of a mcgruber and like
some of my favorite sketches like are
not sketches that were ever seen like
will and kristen did these characters
called the hair heads when jude law
hosted
this is still possibly the most
expensive live sketch ever produced
because what the hair heads were were
just people whose heads were balls of
hair
and they couldn't talk they just they
were sort of like cousin it from from
adam saying like
yeah but jude law owned a
crystal shop he was the owner of like
fine crystals and the hair heads were
like his worst nightmare because they
come in and they just break everything
and so it was just three walls
of breakaway glass crystal things that
had to be purchased and the sketch was
written as a runner meaning it came back
two more times throughout the show oh my
god oh my god
forte did a sketch called finders
keepers with alec baldwin where it was
just alec baldwin parked his car at the
beach and it was a windy day and when it
came back it was mostly covered in sand
and will forte had a metal detector and
he found the car and he says it's his
car now like
what i just said what i just said was
more dialogue than was in the sketch
i think it's baldwin going i'm pretty
sure i parked my car here and and then
you see fortnight
he finds his keepers and he's like what
are you doing that's my car nobody it's
mine now and he launches into a song
that goes finders keepers losers weepers
it's the love of the beach
it's the most insane thing
this whole sketch is just him singing
the rules of finders keepers
it's the law of the beast the law of the
beast
who who is the guy that he did that was
um he had a voice will calhoun yeah will
calhoun i i i believe that's what uh or
tim tim calhoun
yeah
i mean yeah so that's a classic forte
like last sketch probably like a
chopping block oh he's my favorite
that's always my favorite favorite so
that's well that's what i love about
mokiki i mean right which has been in my
head all day because i i watch mokiki um
at least at least once a year awesome um
did it become it must have been
frustrating then i mean i imagine
knowing your strengths i remember
thinking like oh terence shouldn't just
he's playing the dad again on this thing
and like
you know that frustrated me as a fan of
yours that's nice of you you know i've
i've done a lot of work on me and and my
relationship that to that show because
it was so consuming and yeah i've been
able to take a lot more responsibility
for
you know for my journey there i'm very
proud of my journey you know i was um
you should be um
i i i remember feeling at the time
that like i'm pitching sketches that
where i am the star and i'm a weirdo
but when they go back to decide what
sketches are in the show
there's i'm in five other sketches doing
doing service and support so when
they're like who's light in the show
uh yeah they're not gonna worry about me
they'll be like well we can get rid of
that so
and knowing that i'm also
this is where i'm taking responsibility
knowing that i'm not writing if i'm
writing sketches that are not get out of
the park home runs they're gonna put
that in the show
uh-huh but i feel like even mokiki isn't
a knock it out of the park home run
thing it's like a weird thing that's
going to connect to a very specific
audience and those are the things that i
love that i'm passionate about
because because i am able to do the
straight man and utility roles and
because i also am able to do impressions
like i have i had a lot of use to the
show i think i think i took good care of
the show
certainly
was felt i was missing out on
opportunities
to to play in my own weird uh uh sandbox
it didn't surprise me when i saw you
were doing hamilton um knowing your
skill set and level of commitment but
were people were your agents like huh
you want to do what was that a strange
choice for anybody in your
life or was that just that was just a
thrill everybo everybody knew
the significance of being asked and and
i met tommy kale through doing 24-hour
plays which we
kind of did together a couple times and
he and i became close
and we already knew lynn because lynn
had done some writing on how i met your
mother he was asked by neil patrick
harris to do some musical pieces because
neil loved in the heights like like all
of us did and so we were already kind of
friendly with lin but then tommy and i
got became close
it was already such a hit it was already
the the album was out it was already a
phenomenon yeah i felt so honored and
thrilled and the fact that i love to
share is that
this is a hundred percent true in the
three months
i was in hamilton i got more requests
for tickets
to that than in the six years
oh really well yeah which
which you know the people are still
asking about snl certainly it doesn't
speak to like
people not wanting to see snl it just
shows the desire how big
of people who wanted to to be yeah in
the room where it happened see your
rendition of king george how many months
did you do that three months i did 99
shows i had to call out sick one show
and it killed me
how sick were you very very sick so sick
that the show i'm most proud of like i'm
sure you can appreciate this having done
runs the show that i remember the best
i'm most proud of is that show before i
had to call out
literally
would be sweating
and shaking sweating and shaking my
dressing room
and then i'd go out for the first song
i performed it there's i feel very
confident you would not know anything
was wrong i'd go off stage i'd get the
cape off i'd remove the crown i'd go up
and i'd just puke into the toilet oh you
might
and then like yeah and then like trying
not to [ __ ] my pants as an ensemble
member at the end of that show sitting
up you know oh
tell us your story and then like running
off stage and just evacuating everything
like
like that was taking
the willpower commitment to a next level
where i just had to go my body is not my
own right now i have to do this show my
body is on my own
and then just crumbling off stage well
thanks for listening to life is short
you've been um it's been fun doing the
show uh yeah i know that feeling i had
it once and i won't go into detail but
um i remember thinking like afterwards
the sweat that you're producing like the
moisture that's coming out of your body
i don't know how much of it to to
attribute to
the sickness itself or like the
nerves the anxiety of like potentially
[ __ ] your pants on
on a broadway stage it would be i
remember thinking like that will
my no one's talking about my performance
or it's not a thing that's in the news
or anything nor should it be but that
will be in the news that will be
uh you know
it'll make
a it'll be like a headline it'll
certainly be on twitter right
uh really scary patti lupone
yells
yeah yeah uh you do it every year
fantasy football
are sundays in the kilim smolders
smolders kill him household just
reserve do they just know that
daddy is busy that day no i try i try
not to disappear for the day i encourage
them to participate with me when there's
a when there's a rams away game
you know a a healthy marriage and a
healthy parenthood is all about
communication and so i just i make i let
them know hey just so you know in the
morning is the rams game and and
if there are things they need help with
if it's a chores day i mean i can
balance both
it is more the home games that require
my absence more because and so like
so away games are very manageable home
games is sort of like i'm going and they
always they they are the first to be
invited where did that come from were
you into that when you were a kid i
always loved football like football is
definitely tied to my big bear
childhood
there's a little bit of like a friday
night lights town quality to big bear
and the high school football team's big
our neighbors the mazers were huge 49ers
fans
and then we had and then the um
uh god the prospects i think where there
was the family name they were huge uh
green bay fans and they held big super
bowl parties and so like i just loved
the tradition of it i loved the like
gathering and putting your name in the
box and rooting for your team oh yeah
and i just never felt like i had a team
of my own and then i started doing
fantasy football in college and promised
myself very early on like when la gets a
team again because i knew he would i'm
all in on him oh oh so you weren't a
rams fan growing up
no i'm just jewish
did you know that did i tell you this
that i was weirdly even though i grew up
in the east coast yes
for some reason i well i know the reason
it's
it's not very
macho but i like their uniforms i
thought they'd like to yeah
we did a preseason game together and
last season we got to go and you got to
see me lose my mind and get a fight with
a child yeah you really did
get you you
squared off with a kid who
in your defense the kid started it
he
started
that's what i mean about your level of
commitment even with something like that
enjoying a football game you were
you were really going at it with this
kid and um
where does that come from that that
level of excitement about
and it was a preseason game yeah
i think i think what i like is uh about
football more than anything is the is
the communal feel you know what i mean
like
you were leading a lot of chance you
were into like we're doing this and yeah
there's a preciousness to the games
because there's not as many in the
season like it's hard
i couldn't do that for baseball oh god i
love seeing a baseball game because i
love like sitting and talking and
chatting but like yeah for 160 82 games
or whatever you can't have so there's a
precious oh you'd have a heart attack
exactly yeah um
i'm sure i buy into sort of the machismo
of american sport you know this is the
man the man's game um that's diminished
over time i know it started there and
that's diminished as you sort of like
read the reports on cte and you
understand the the risks and the damage
that these players are doing to
themselves and
and and so i you know
i
i have definitely kind of like
altered my enthusiasm for aspects of the
game you know let's have a really let's
have a really graceful throw
oh i love some of those cheers
my brother
[Laughter]
yeah control the clock
yeah
yeah we like sharing uh for both i like
cheering for the um
just a great play you know like i never
understood the idea that because
somebody was wearing a different uniform
they make a great play or
why you have to boo them or you know
like
or even worse this is what i hate the
most when i when i watch this uh happen
with football when somebody gets injured
like you were saying
and and
you know you hear teams
taunting still or there's not a sense
that like i mean at a certain point it
becomes
um
like what are we doing this is these are
human beings definitely yeah i think i
think the enthusiasm there's certainly
like a self-awareness of
there's there's a sliver of irony you
know yeah like we're going crazy
like i really would compare it to going
to medieval times i love the medieval
times and i love getting all in on my
night
oh i was like cable guy
truly rednecks going down it all comes
back to jim carrey yeah it does um so i
love i love getting getting i see you
let's go uh we i fight him one of my
best friends hunter i i was his best man
so i organized his bachelor party in
vegas and we went to tournament of kings
there and i made sure we were in the
dragon night the dragonite's kind of the
villain of the show in his section and
our bachelor party were the most
obnoxious
i know that we ruined that experience
for others and and anybody who's wanna
who wants to complain like how dare you
were so loud i was like you are at
tournament of king
at excalibur in las vegas for dinner if
you are not yelling your head off you
are not getting your money's worth even
when you were
having this like
uh shouting match with this kid
the kids parents were right there they
were laughing there was some it came
from a place of it was just a tiny
little degree of innocence that you had
where you were like oh really look at
the scoreboard no no no and the kid was
giving it back to you and it was it was
like you were two kids who were just
like yeah
both understood that the stakes weren't
that high and wasn't like a serious
thing you were it was almost like it was
like a playful fight with a kid i've
never seen an adult really commit to a
playful fight with a kid a stranger's
kid
and kevin was doing it for money too
that's what really that's where i really
dug in because like his uncle or
something like gave him 20 bucks and
he's like go harass that guy he's a big
rams fan so i was like oh really yeah
yeah so bricks bring it on yeah oh then
again the environment of that and none
of my taunts are like
you know you're a pathetic little kid
and
you're gonna live a life of sorrow
um
it's all out of like yeah let's do it
let's see how much you got bud life
could be a dream sweetheart
hello hello again you're booming over
we'll meet again
[Music]
um all right i could do this all day
short questions great uh lightning round
yes sir what is your most commonly used
emoji um i think i think a thumbs up
okay yeah that's pretty standard
a thumbs up or a crooked tears out of
the eyes laughing oh okay did you would
you do that instead of writing hahaha
uh i write i have to write hahaha and it
comes up and i click it i'm not going i
still haven't mastered the quick emoji
board
i haven't either yeah no
if uh you could have one snack food for
the rest of your life uh what what would
it be um uh hot tamales
hot tamales oh my god i haven't had a
hot tamale in a
year jesus yeah huh
are you you're really into it like
cinnamony i like them i i like i like
i like them i like them i eat them i
like them i enjoy them
they move through me all right
um
it's like uh yeah they've they've just
always kind of been my favorite movie
snack candy yeah just put them away i
can i'm not like anything chocolatey
feels pretty heavy very quickly i'm not
a sour guy and i'm not as like
starbursty taffy sweet guy either so
it's got the gummy and the cinnamon
and i uh uh like i'll really spoil
myself with hot tamales and a mountain
dew
oh wow oh my god you were wondering
where my commitment comes from they're
my energy
a combination
you drink them out you oh man i would no
i ingested anally
okay all right yeah
mountain dew enema
classic taren um
that is such a great taren combination
that is such a great i'd love to see you
after one of those
after you you
take
i hope you enjoyed it
um
what i was gonna ask about your favorite
movie but uh i also want to really quick
ask about gun killing gunther what we
never really talked about schwarzenegger
what was
that experience like you this is a movie
you directed a couple years ago i'm not
telling you
yes no for the listening audience this
year you remember this right i recall um
it was yeah it was it was the most
fulfilling thing i've worked on just
because i
learned more doing that than anything
and i was in en engaged and responsible
for so many elements and this is a movie
that i'd written thinking like what's
something
super stupid and and and silly
like in the genre of a luke bassan or
john mctiernan action movie that i love
that genre which i would never be cast
in
done in the style of like a guest
guffman kind of mockumentary thing
and we'll do it super cheap but we'll do
it just on the sly and it'll look stupid
and the point of it will be like
these are not real these people would
never be hitmen and you know there's
nothing threatening about these people
um
and then in just getting financing and
chopping it around and pitching it we
were pitched
arnold schwarzenegger for like kind of
the cameo reveal at the end of the movie
and
and
he said yeah he somehow said yeah
and like crazy
it's it's yeah it's insane because
he i mean jim carrey like my hero but
arnold schwarzenegger movies were the
you know oh the yang of the jim carrey
yin to me
yeah and so and the first rated our
movie i saw was terminator 2
um
like in honors and it just i couldn't
believe it and um
and and i played it cool and i was
professional i tried to wear my
directing hat and be respectful this is
when you have a meeting with him taran
yeah it was like through
skype meetings at first and like him
calling from his son valley home in
idaho and being like here's what i'm
going to do i'm going to read the script
it's really i think it's a great
character for me because it it sort of
builds off of things that people know me
for and i was like yeah arnold i agree
with that uh
and then
and going to his house and like pitching
him and and meeting with him there and
like when he when he when he the first
time i like talked to him was over
facetime and he was in his this lodge in
sun valley and he's got a huge oil
painting behind him from his like
pumping iron days like bodybuilder and
he's sitting there at his desk with us
again he's like tyrion how are you
that's the before this is the after
it was the best
definitely done that joke
oh god
and
should continue
yeah it's what the painting's for yeah
exactly oh my god what and at that point
had he already committed to doing it
when you when you go out there to talk
no no so he then he read it after that
and then he called me and um
he said yeah i think i want to do it
let's do it and so then i flew out to la
to kind of talk to him about the vision
and how i saw the character and the
design and everything and this is still
during negotiations so like it's another
thing that's sort of mine to lose and
yeah
and you got to be impressive you got to
impress him exactly and um i did i
worked really hard and i think he had a
good time filming it and i think
i think him in the movie is certainly by
far the best thing like people who watch
it
that you know they're pretty lukewarm if
anything people i think mostly didn't
care for it but nobody has been like
arnold was awful in this movie every
every like negative review was like who
are these people this is not engaging
this is so unfunny but when you get to
arnold it's really funny and worth it so
like that was enough of an
accomplishment like that i just didn't
want to kind of let him down
um yeah
and and having him up there was the best
is is that something you'd like to do
again i mean was the experience good
enough yeah oh yeah definitely
uh okay what what is your favorite movie
what what is the movie that you in
quarantine have been really um has been
very comforting would you say well my
favorite all time is star wars a new
hope that's just like the number number
one um star wars um
i can always go back to about a boy
that's always comforting um it's a
wonderful life as a perennial that is
always and and i don't always
necessarily just watch it around
christmas time
um
we've been doing the mcu the girls
haven't seen all of the marvel stuff so
we're we just finished infinity war so
we have like two more to go three more
together oh yeah i thought man crush
university
yeah exactly exactly what uh top gun do
you remember you know do you
remember when you saw star wars for the
first time was that when you sat on like
a v no vhs no it's always just been in
my mind
like literally like raised on it from
before i was
cognitive
your uh brothers are younger you have
two younger one younger brother and then
a younger sister and two older sisters
two older sisters okay uh i'm just
trying to think because i i think you're
you're a couple years younger so i think
you just missed the theater yeah
theatric like the run of that i was one
i was one when jedi came out in theaters
uh-huh okay um
and and uh
have you auditioned for any of those
movies the styles no yeah either way i
know
oh but i heard you're also a big teenage
mutant ninja turtle fan huge and some
and got your and somehow got into the
movie just convinced them to give you
a small role
yeah yeah yeah big big big
um
jonathan lieberman who directed that
like he they connected me just because i
just i just loved turtles and
um
yeah he was he was like um okay sure i
think there's this role that maybe you
can do where you're like a news reporter
i was like great i just want to be in
the turtles and then i remember being on
set and and i was like do you think like
do you think like i could put in
something like uh you know we've also
got reports of like organized rats
stealing from you know like little like
easter eggs of like like rat king and
then a future and he like was so not as
invested in the lore like he did a good
job on the movie but he was just not
clearly
wasn't watching it every morning before
school like i was where he's like why
would you what would you say about rats
and i was like well i just could say
like i'm doing a list so maybe i say
different things like like a human they
say there's a human fly and that'd be
like baxter stockman and stuff and he's
just like
well let's just do what's just do what's
in the script
was this before you directed your movie
yeah yeah yeah okay all right before you
knew that like at that point like it's
not going to get cut out anymore right
exactly yeah it would be worth doing
anyway yeah right
it's funny
uh so oh i want to see that you so you
did a day on that yeah just just did
like it's so fun
uh if you had to live somewhere else
where where would it be
um hawaii
oh yeah maui
you guys go there we used to go a lot
and we haven't we're supposed to go
right before the quarantine of it also
now i'm really really hungry for it it's
just the only place i've ever been where
as soon as you're off the plane like
just on the jet way it's just like ah
yeah yeah
that's beautiful yeah the air yeah um
if you could have dinner with three
people dead or alive whom you've never
met walt disney madeline khan howard
ashman oh wow what a great
lineup yeah oh god madeline khan yeah is
just a brilliant yeah i've been i've
been uh what did i see the other day
madeline khan is so [ __ ] great and
you think about her all the performances
that were oh my god the funniest
deprived
yes yeah no she's the funniest ever
oh great list um
who's your favorite muppet kermit
uh-huh yeah easy
rainbow connection
yeah
like yeah animal's a distant second
do you do any of the muppets uh sure
yeah everybody hi ho everybody does a
kermit hey there justin
or when your daughters were younger you
were reading these books do you
i can imagine you just being like the
best at reading kids books to this i am
currently reading harry potter to our
five-year-old and oh wow
killing it
i bet uh
who if you had to be one age for the
rest of your life physically what would
you pick
probably like you know what you know now
you have all the 34.
uh-huh
you're now 38
38. um four years on the downslide brah
are you
you um
hey what is that cake i was trying to
get kobe's cake coconut cake
yeah where's the coconut tom cruise
it's the tom cruise cake that's right
yeah do you still get it do you still
get that cake oh yes
yes here's the thing so for a guy who
eats hot tamales and drinks mountain dew
it's actually kind of sweet for me the
white chocolateness of it is almost too
sweet but kobe doesn't like sweet things
and she loves it i really like it it's
good but she
loves it
huh did you me when she was filming that
uh oh yeah jack richard you met you
meant the best the best yeah yeah we
talk about him all the time
what was he like just so like
immediately charming right he's doing
everything right he's doing everything
right he's doing research on people he's
retaining everything
we get called to set because kobe's
filming in the jack reacher thing and
he walks up and he goes straight to shay
our our oldest daughter and he's like
hey i'm tom i really like working with
your mom it's so nice to meet you she
talks about you all the time you know
you're just like yep you're great yeah
and and shay's holding at the time like
a gel like a lighting gel
like uh you got a little souvenir there
and an and like idiot that i am and i'm
like i'm gonna insert myself and make a
joke i'm like yeah careful shay he's a
producer so he he can charge you for
that
actually i'm a producer so i can tell
her she can have it and i was like oh
the best you're the [ __ ] god you're
the best you're the best and then and
then they're like we've been waiting
because they don't call him until
they're ready to roll we've been waiting
and
he goes have you seen the set we're
gonna shoot on shay it's your mommy's
office it's come check it out takes a
full 10 minutes the crew's waiting to
like look at how cool is this your mom's
like a major and kind of explaining the
character and taking things off the
walls and showing shay all about shea
and then you're just wow this is i love
this one
and then my favorite favorite favorite
part of my first introduction of time
you're like taking
adult like notes from him oh my god this
is how you do it this is how you do it
my favorite favorite is that they go
okay okay and tom's only on set because
it's a phone call so he's just there to
read off camera with coke amazing
amazing amazing yeah so
people should know that that is
actors like with of half his
stature don't always do that correct i
mean that's something that people will
literally phone it in from their home
exactly you know exactly wow wow he's
there doing the other side of the phone
let's go to video village
and
and they go oh you can walk around and
they're like oh you can cut through
there but there's a door that's kind of
blocked by like a c stand or whatever
and then and tom's like we'll just sneak
through there and like shake and sneak
right through and then i go and he kind
of like playfully pushes me like he's
being close with me
and i'm already wearing i'm already
wearing my comm tech and he pushes me
and so the comm tech like kind of
scrapes my stomach
you get it and like i didn't want to
like
first of all i didn't want to show pain
in front of tom cruise oh sure you can i
just could never ever ever ever ever
tell him about it
yeah but while they're doing the first
rehearsal and he's fully committed to
the rehearsal while he's doing it i'm
just like watching the monitors going
cool cool checking down like looking at
my bleeding stomach cool cool cool
and then
also i don't know what shape your
stomach was in at the time exactly but i
imagine it's not tom cruise not you know
it was excess i i was it was pre-keto so
um
and then and then this is the best part
this is the best part of the story and
then uh i'll stop talking but um
they do the rehearsal we're watching
shay's listening to the thing watching
the monitors and it's a phone call and
then kobe is a joke at the end of the
rehearsal there's like you know that
awkward the scene is over and you're
sitting waiting for cut and kobe just
goes
what are you wearing
and everybody goes
but tom goes
[Music]
and the director goes cut all right and
he goes i'm gonna do one adjustment
and he turns to shay and he looks at it
and he goes
your mother is very funny
turns to me and goes kind of like your
dad
oh my god
and i will die for him
i'd like to point out to the listeners
that taryn is weeping
is currently weeping it was the greatest
a person can be
that's how you be a person
oh man um it's so strange to and i
i want to say this delicately it's
because we do like wax poetic about him
often and i think
i love his movies and i love these
stories about him that he is such a wild
impressive performer and person and
so all that other stuff that i don't
even want to like
say
is
i don't know what to do with it in my
appreciation of him and
in my reverence for uh how what a
charming human moment that is that like
what he did with your daughter so it's
like
i don't know he's an undeniable movie
star he's one of the most prolific
cinematic screen presences in history
yeah um
and it's almost like you have to talk
about two different people and and
i have no first-hand experience with the
other stuff really you know
yeah
and that's hard to say that i've learned
in being judgmental and cynical um yeah
i have learned that about
everyone across the board you learn it
at snl having a different host each week
is like oh i bet you have to you have to
base your
relationship and your opinions of people
based on first-hand experience because
you just never know where someone's
coming from you never know what
someone's going through you know
yeah you you yeah that's right every
week a different and i imagine a whole
different tone a whole different energy
for sure and i i had read that you said
eddie murphy was your favorite yeah
host is that yeah yeah what what was it
about was he
game was he oh about about hosting i he
never hosted when i was there he hosted
after he came for the 40th and that was
wonderful um but but jim carrey hosted
while i was there he was oh wow he was
like the eighth show of my first year it
was crazy and i got you get two and i
gotta sketch on and like
literally doing animatronic physical
comedy together side by side and uh
wow one of the coolest professional
moments of my life
i bet did you get to tell him oh yeah
what about the 40th actually i was like
you know i mean you've you've been
around and i know we've like worked
together but i got to tell you what you
mean to me and he's like i get it i
understand you know i'm standing here
and i look down this hallway and i go
that's bill [ __ ] murray
that's good that's good
your face just took on
his appearance that was incredible uh
yeah okay if you could be reincarnated
as a non-human animal what would it be
that's the the tricky one i'm gonna say
i'm gonna say eagle just for the
physical sensation of flight
yeah
would you rather be called unattractive
or unfunny
unattractive
uh-huh um which golden girl do you most
identify with dorothy blanche rose or
sophia um
b arthur who yeah dorothy yeah uh dogs
are cats do you prefer cats
really yeah
huh yeah did you have or dogs
so sorry did you
we have a cat yeah we have kylie cat
they're just more self-sufficient i had
a great dog growing up magic um loved
him he was half husky half newfoundland
loyal dog but um he was so much work um
and do you ever think about uh
how do you want how you want to be
remembered um both as a performer as a
person
versatile as a performer
uh decent as a person well i can i can
attest to both
yeah very good you just
turned just raised his fist and face i
just did uh i just did a jud nelson fist
pump yeah
and that's how you podcast don't you
forget about um oh man i could talk to
you
another couple hours but uh i know you
gotta go this has been fun oh good i
can't wait to tell christian i look
forward to his uh analysis after the
show that's what i'll be tuning in for
he's a fan he uh he was very flattered
by the fact that you wanted him yeah
here but it's great i love the show and
and you're the best and i haven't spent
any time with him but but i feel like i
have through listening to the show and
the longs are good folk well
as are the kilns smolders you would you
would like each other uh so maybe in la
i would love that i would love that okay
thanks buddy thank you i say hi i will i
will bye dude
[Music]
well that happened
[Applause]
that happened it's such a great
character and he doesn't give himself
enough credit because i think it is
different than roger right i mean roger
rabbit also did that
i can't do it but
i can't do it please eddie please
eddie eddie that's hard to do who did
that
do you remember
no but he was a comedian who used to
perform at the comedy store a lot we met
him one night i think i may be thinking
of somebody else he was a brilliant
mathematician remember that guy oh yeah
he was like a brilliant i knew i knew
that i was somehow aware of that guy and
there was something about him yeah there
was something kind of like uh you know
he reminded me of the the villain in
babes and toyland either someone kind of
like sinister about him and and he was
like um a genius he was uh
he wasn't evil but he reminded me of he
was evil he was just sinister yeah
yes yeah it was so talented such a funny
i mean but unique performer anyway um
speaking of funny and unique uh what did
you think of that what a guy yeah you
love him well you know you're glowing
uh am i yeah i got a little glowy i knew
you'd
you'd really yeah well i gotta say i
are you now hearing his impression of
you a little bit
well i i think um
his wife i just met briefly when she was
a guest and
i thought she just couldn't have been
warmer and kinder
um when i met her and and he strikes me
as the exact same way yeah they're they
seem in that way in terms of their
warmth it's pretty amazing they seem
perfectly matched yeah and i don't my
frame of reference is pretty limited
when it comes to couples too i hate to
say this like i know
actor couples and couples in my business
uh a lot more intimately than i know
other couples i would say and and so
maybe maybe this is not uncommon for
like
people outside of
show business to
be to you know being a very warm to be
too warm funny loving people but
i don't know
i know a lot of couples and i would i
would classify them rare couple goals
yeah oh yeah i think that's fair to say
i think so
uh yeah they and it's not because they
just sent us a delicious looking batch
of ghostly those looks like really good
adherence to those to tarantulas
oh boy
uh yeah he what did what did you think i
mean let's address the elephant the
elephant in the room is that your
impression of me that's my impression of
him his impression of you what's your
impression of me what's your impression
of me um whenever we'd answer the phone
right you know when i tried to like
pretend it was you on the phone
like if mom or somebody called uh or if
somebody was like calling looking for
you and i pretend to be you it was like
uh hello yeah you would do
uh you would always do like a slightly
deeper
duller version of your own voice
and maybe that's what what it is
perfect but it's also you don't give up
as much as that you're not as eager when
you answer the phone as i am so i would
also
that's how i was playing it was like
you didn't give up as much like um
yeah
hello
well i will say it's not yeah it
i don't think it was the most flattering
impression
i've ever heard but i will also say that
you know imitation is the sincerest form
of flattery so i have no
noteworthy person has to my knowledge
has ever done an impression of me yeah
that's cool so uh it's pretty cool that
alone i know makes me feel pretty
special that's what i thought you don't
both have to think that it's special
that anyone's doing an impression of you
uh my friends this will make you feel
better you've heard do you remember
togo's my friend john toga's impression
of me uh who's a very good he's very
funny and and good at impressions
and his of me is like oh hey guys hey
what's going on you know who has a bad
impression of you too uh former friend
of the show current front of the show
not jerry
i knew you're gonna say it's terrible
oh it's terrible okay
do you want to come out uh do you want
to come out with me tonight wait he just
did an impression of oh somebody else a
director friend of mine and it sounded
exactly like that and then he did it i
think all of his impressions kind of
sound like that of people who are uh
more beta than he is well that
that
i will say though i have heard uh that h
john benjamin comparison before yeah
more than a few times i know
made me laugh and uh
i wouldn't mind getting some of that
voice over work that that guy's getting
yeah i'll take some of the that spill
off yeah some some of the uh stuff that
h can't do
would you just call him h if h is on
holiday
and he's not available i'll i'll step in
yeah h christian long wouldn't mind uh
doing that
um yeah why not i mean you do have a
good voice a rich it's like a deep rich
creamy it's got a timber timbre uh
timbre uh i don't know but yeah it was
it was cool that he did it and he was
also he's so quick it's and then you
hear his other impressions and like like
like a lot of my favorite impressionists
they're he's not like rich little where
he's like it sounds or that guy he
mentioned who performs in vegas where
it's like oh that sounds just like the
person right he's capturing like an
essence of them in a funny way he's
right i like his pasty impression
yes yeah you'd i would in fact great it
was like uh dan and carvey doing george
bush you know exactly exactly i always
think about that he captures
in in essence yeah yeah i mean like
george bush doesn't necessarily yeah
it's well said but he did but he did do
an impression that was
michael sarah schwarzenegger was oh
incredible yeah that did sound like you
both had to think your shorts saying
your impression was incredible
wait but i bet you can do
a better pacey
um you do a good pacey goodbye timmer
goodbye to me bye bye tomorrow tammy
he just doesn't open his mouth very much
i you know i was listening to the uh
interview again and i felt the need to
jump in and and now i i
want to take this opportunity to say how
much i like joshua jackson like we
should have we were kind of like it
sounded like we were making fun of him
but i don't think so i think oh really
no it was a character played 25 years
ago i know but it didn't open his mouth
a lot when he talk i know but it might
if he were listening to this it might
sound like i just want to give him all
right well that's true i don't i don't
think i didn't feel like
that was necessary oh okay i think he's
a really for the record i know you like
him i think he's a really good actor i
actually saw him i also thought he was
really good on that show oh correctly
great by the way
what a great what it's an iconic show
yeah
um bye tammy goodbye tammy uh but it was
great but taryn um
is like you said he's so quick and he is
and now i feel a little self-conscious
talking about him because i
i'm pretty sure he's listening
so
so uh i'm a little afraid to sound like
yeah you're you're tiptoe first
impression of me yes
but i will compliment him and say that
uh he is
so quick and game and willing he is like
when you ask him to do something you're
like oh dude in this case an impression
of me or any or like the way he agreed
to do mad tv i know he
is so brave well that he he like agrees
to things before the questions even i i
i so admire listen fearless 19 years old
he does that show that was my impression
when i sang karaoke with him that he was
getting up in front of all these really
like
impressive people like
snl veterans and like fancy pants actors
were in that room and he was just
getting up and having and having fun not
in like a show-off way like look what i
can do it was all in the spirit of fun
like i just [ __ ] loved him right away
and
i to he's like that um even the game
night that we did we played mafia on
zoom the other night as i mentioned and
he was the host so he was running the
whole thing and um
was so quick and and just but enough i
don't know i don't know how to say in
just such a fun way he's like such a
great guy to like
play games with and and you know i would
imagine like a party at their house is
really fun oh yeah he's just such a who
would
like an oscar wilde i don't know who who
would that be a guy like that like um
a guy that you want by the way he's a
guy that i would want if i didn't know
him he's the type of guy that i would
want at my you know we asked a question
about like who would you want to have
dinner with oh yeah he'd be a great
facilitator you know he'd be a good guy
to mc a wedding oh yeah that sounds like
an insult but it's actually i
uh sure taran
are you interested
you do your impression of me christian
is getting married uh
i wonder if people know that christian
uh recently got engaged
you make it sound like it just happened
to me
yeah yeah it just came upon you
you just um oh my god what is this
speaking of getting engaged uh the way
he was talking about his wife i could i
could almost hear
the female listeners of the show like
not you know well because it's uh it's
honest too you can tell that it's honest
and he um
he speaks that way about her off you
know
in privately as well so
i can i can attest to their uh affection
for one another not that you need me to
listeners here's a criticism or taran uh
his
his choice of
hot tamales
oh that's his favorite
weird why is that a criticism
i think it's really bizarre
wow really bizarre oh you're usually
very open to different types of snacks
well i've had hot tamales you just don't
like them i don't dislike them but have
many in a row oh my god
they're like it's way too spicy
and and gummy to have too many but
there's something great about that
because taran also has this great um
there's a there's like an absurdist side
to him there's he's weird too you know i
know yeah so it's sort of it's it's
fitting well i've i've never heard
someone say i don't like
i'm not i'm not a chocolate guy i'm not
a sour guy and i'm not a sweet like
gummy guy it's like well i guess the
only thing on my hot
tamales
he literally picked the one thing that
was left after eliminating every other
time it's like i like mics but i don't
like ikes
i by the way i have nothing against if
they became a sponsor red hots do you
you used to love it i don't mind i like
cinnamon i like youtube i really like
red hot desserts i like them yeah but to
snack on them but to pick it as your
favorite and yeah to have many of them
to like eat them throughout a movie now
i'm so hung up on like how taren it
would respond to your criticisms
oh that's
they're just it's just bizarre that um a
cinnamon should be such a sound
it's too much uh it's too butthead it's
too mike no but i'm doing his version of
you i guess it is a little yeah it was
but eddie i loved his tom cruise story i
it's so fun to picture him
being around tom cruise and being giddy
i know i
know i know and and i mean like
it hurt his stomach how he like bumped
into him and he like really hurt his
stomach but he couldn't he couldn't
express it it's such a made me laugh so
hard he's also such a good storyteller
because he sets he includes like just
all the relevant information right he's
such a good storyteller you know he is
uh and funny in the re-enacting and like
self-deprecating and he's just
he all he said about tom cruise he said
he's doing everything right
and i would say that about him yeah
let's read a letter okay
are you forcing your voice up a little
bit to sound less like does it sound
like i am no i don't i don't mean to be
no maybe a little oh weird
okay this is a letter from stephanie s
subject cumberland island and um anna
emoji what else how would you describe
that it's like a gridded teeth emoji
like uh my favorite like like this
oh um i use that a lot me too uh i use
it for like oh oh it means you're like
oh
maybe i shouldn't say that i do it when
i make like a cheesy joke on instagram
right i wonder what word corresponds to
that i'm curious how she was using it
now and what kind what wait sorry to
read that readout the subject is just
cumberland island oh well let's find out
yeah okay here we go we don't have
enough information no that's limited
justin and christian i love the show and
have been listening from the beginning
ah thank you stephanie
life is short was my very first podcast
subscription whoa that's really cool
since i've heard it come up more than
once now i wanted to share that
cumberland island is off the coast of
saint mary's georgia a small town 90
minutes south of savannah that's right
the ferry to the island the ferry to the
island there's no bridge docks at
historic downtown st mary's near the
lovely waterfront park st mary's
submarine museum and historic oak grove
cemetery st mary's is also home to
crooked river state park and adjacent to
kings bay naval submarine base wow
i wonder if she works there savannah is
one of my favorite places to visit and
while there are several beautiful
islands off its coast cumberland is not
one of them
huh
thanks so much for hosting such a fun
entertaining show
it's sincerely stephanie s a saint
mary's native and a dorothy
oh so i should have read that in more of
um the arthur way cumberland island is
not one of them
p.s i spent two your dorothy impression
is a little bit like your impression uh
yeah well the shoe fits yeah yes i spent
two summers at berkshire theatre
festival and enjoy listening to you talk
about your summer stock experiences in
the berkshires i hate snowy places but i
love summers and the berkshires
i love them too but i i also love snowy
teams uh okay would you rather i kind of
should we first get to that cumberland
island uh dis whoa you just spazzed your
eyes just spam oh really yeah cumberland
island uh was it a dis i don't think
this i didn't read it that way she said
savannah is one of my favorite places to
visit and while there are several
beautiful islands of islands off its
coast cumberland is not one of them i i
i read that more as um
there are so many more beautiful that i
should be talking about yeah yeah yeah
well i have i don't get the credit they
deserve uh-huh oh that's a nice way of
uh you're a real stephanie slusser
apologist
um
i i've always wanted to go to tybee
tybee island um that's where they shot
the baywatch remake
and among other things but um yeah i'd
love to go back there god i love that
place what's that awesome place in in
georgia that we we stop and with that
great coffee pooler pooler georgia great
tacos great town great town great coffee
shop
huh i'm curious though what she doesn't
like about cumberland island i just
thought it was so beautiful but i guess
there are more beautiful places i should
explore or maybe cumberland island has
gone to hell since you've been oh maybe
yeah maybe because it was i was
surprised by how untouched it seemed
maybe she would
disagree okay would you rather would you
rather would you rather get a splinter
every time you touch something ugh or
burn your tongue every time you eat
something that's a good one wait does
that mean every time you go to bite
something or every meal like once a meal
well i would imagine it's every time you
put something in your mouth
then in that case i think i'd rather get
a splinter every time i would just avoid
touching things
yeah it's probably easier to avoid
touching things oh also this you pick up
a fork once you get a splinter do you
get uh a splinter from picking up food
that's a good question and then you burn
yourself how about this how about this
if you don't
if the splinter thing doesn't apply to
picking up food
with your hands you're saying right yeah
i think it's a pretty clear
i hate splinters though i think you you
just avoid touching things you get one
splinter or you get splinters all over
your hands like i'm imagining making a
smoothie and
like lifting the handle i hate that
feeling of getting a splinter it almost
never how here's the question what
happens to you more
do you get a splinter or do you burn
your tongue uh that's a good question i
think i burned my tongue more although
this summer i got more splinters than
burnt tongues
because i was i was touching a lot more
wood
uh
speaking of my impression of taryn's
impression of you uh i think i burned my
tongue more too i don't do either very
often don't either you know what i burn
more than my tongue and this is probably
what she means this would probably apply
that the roof of my mouth mmm i don't i
burn that a lot more than my actual you
do yeah
yeah because you know you get that
little i think yeah because i i put the
food in like this and it gets like i i
don't i don't like it i don't set it on
my tongue when i first put food in my
mouth but isn't it the first thing to
receive the food your tongue is it
i'm trying to imagine eating now uh i
think it's the top well actually like
pizza think about that last night we by
the way shout out to mike's pizza in
fairfield i hadn't been there in over 30
years and it's still delicious they
still got it they still got it mike's
pizza fairfield go there um yeah but
like eating pizza the first thing that
would burn
you bite down but if you also if you put
a spoon or a fork into your mouth the
bottom of the spoon
is protected a bit so then the food is
going to hit the top of your mouth so
maybe you're right but still i i think
that would apply to her burning the
mouth thing right hmm
yeah
i would say splinters are
you can avoid them more like you said
that's how it is you can't avoid eating
you need to eat to survive
you don't need to touch things to
survive i think i enjoy eating more than
i like touching things or that that's
gives me more pleasure well i mean so
you'll take the splinter and just and
it's kind of sad thing to say because
now i'm i'm thinking about i'm
extrapolating that huh
that's a good one
i mean like like it's also easy there's
a difference in splinters between like
you know those splinters those like
glass plastic splinters that you can't
find for like days sometimes but it just
kind of hurts yeah you know you have one
in there but you can't those are awful
splinters suck thank you because it's
not just the pain you're right it's not
just the pain it's the fact that there's
something now in your body that you have
to deal with i know but i was gonna make
a distinction between those kind of
splinters and like if they're just like
a kind of a big wooden splinter that you
can just pull out right that's nothing
really that's true
that's why i would uh if it is if you
can choose what type of splinter and
choose what type of burn if it's just
like a little like
if it's like a burn where you're like
flicking a little piece of skin on the
roof of your mouth i think it's always
that yeah you always get a little i pick
the splinter
okay and just avoid touching things yeah
me too and then you'd enjoy uh you you
only touch things that you really enjoy
i don't think so because then you
wouldn't enjoy them anymore because
every time you touch them you get a
splinter
right
you would just stop touching things you
would just stay in your house this is a
really good one oh thank you for the
letter if you guys would like to write
in our email address is life is short at
wondery.com and thank you to the what
are you doing i was just you know it's
funny we were talking about splinters i
thought i had a little hair growing in
near my nipple
yeah so i just looked to see if it was
in fact uh a hair so thank you to our
guest taryn killum the kind and
hilarious taran killam and thank you all
for listening
and uh
i hope uh you listen next week yeah oh
that was very please keep listening yeah
i was a little desperate
desperate
that's just we you know it was a good
show mostly thanks to taryn
yes so i think people will be encouraged
to listen because i think so too uh and
next week is another very special guest
which well we'll leave it for a surprise
like we always do and also i'm not too
sure who it is
uh thank you to taryn um i can't wait to
go to every time we watch a rams game i
think about him i can't wait to go to a
game with him and to just uh see him
again tally ho tally ho listeners thank
you guys
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it's co-hosted by you christian
long uh who also produces it along with
the likes of megan monaco senior
producer is michelle me lans audio
engineer is sergio enriquez with two
executive producers on this one marshall
louie and hernan lopez for a company
name love
name of wandery
voice memo coming up
[Music]
it's me
nature cat and your uncle justin told me
you're a fan well i'm a fan of you and i
just wanted to wish you a happy
halloween i love halloween because
that's when pumpkins come out
pumpkins odd word and pumpkin word
goodbye
you